recently this happened capture confront
SpaceX launched its crew dragon marking
the first time that a commercially built
crew capsule launched from American soil
this is exciting all on its own but this
upcoming Soyuz launch could also mark
the end of an era and what could be the
last time Americans are sent to space in
a country other than their own
expedition 5960 is expected to launch on
march 14th from the balcony or
cosmodrome in kazakhstan ferrying the
new crew to the ISS including astronauts
from October's failed abort mission the
two astronauts in one cosmonaut will be
joining the crew already aboard the ISS
working on roughly 250 experiments to
further our understanding of the human
body test new technology and even try to
further wrap our brains around what time
means in space this latest mission will
be on a Soyuz ms 12 spacecraft carrying
a three-person crew alexey ovchinin of
the russian space agency Roscosmos NASA
astronauts Christina hammock coke and
Nick Hague 4ov Keenan and Hague this is
their second attempt to make it to the
ISS on October 11th 2018 the pair were
headed for a routine trip to the space
station on a Soyuz rocket but two
minutes after liftoff a problem occurred
during the separation of one of the
Rockets strap-on boosters forcing them
to perform an emergency landing via
ballistic re-entry which sounds scary
and is scary but it's actually the only
way astronauts used to re-enter at the
beginnings of human space travel
since then ovchinin and Hague have been
retrained and are prepared for
expedition 59 60 we got in touch with
Hague currently stationed in Star City
Russia
and spoke to him about his feelings of
heading back after only a few months
well you know if you asked me a year ago
if I'd be in this position I could have
never imagined it so it's a little bit
surreal being able to have another
opportunity this quickly but I feel very
fortunate for the opportunity to be able
to get up there and you know finally get
to doing the mission that I've been
training for at NASA for the last five
years
expedition 5960 will be making history
as they will be on board when the first
Commercial Crew vehicles are scheduled
to arrive at the ISS having launched
from Cape Canaveral in Florida do you
hasn't launched astronauts into space
from its own soil since 2011
since then astronauts have been ferried
to and from Earth via Russian Soyuz
rockets but this agreement is due to run
out by the end of 2019 now there's a
chance that they may have the
opportunity to buy more seats but the
overall goal is to get back to launching
from the US so why did the u.s. stop
ferrying its astronauts to space
officially named the space
transportation system NASA's Space
Shuttle program had its first flight on
April 12th 1981 the space shuttle
program was the world's first reusable
rocket shuttling astronauts repairing
satellites and even helping to build the
ISS during its reign the program had
five space shuttles that flew a total of
135 missions but by 2011 one estimate
put the average cost per trip to roughly
1.5 billion dollars so after 30 years of
service NASA decided to retire the
program since then the US has been
entirely dependent on Russia as the
Soyuz is the only spacecraft available
to transport crews to the ISS and
they're pretty reliable the Soyuz is the
longest operational manned spacecraft in
history although it's expensive the u.s.
currently pays 81 million dollars per
seat for its astronauts two hits arrive
which is why in 2014 NASA decided to
spend its coin in the private sector
awarding both SpaceX and Boeing with
contracts to build spacecraft that could
shuttle astronauts in the long term this
also means that NASA has more resources
available to tackle challenges like deep
space exploration and getting to Mars to
be ready for the task
SpaceX built its crew Dragon spacecraft
that sits atop a falcon 9 its first test
flight dubbed demonstration 1 launched
on March 2nd from Kennedy Space Center
making history as the first commercially
made American spacecraft and rocket to
launch from the US after a day in
Earth's orbit the capsule successfully
docked into the ISS delivering its
spacesuit sensor wearing test device
named Ripley and roughly 180 kilograms
of supplies
it remained docked for roughly five days
before making its descent back to earth
splashing down into the Atlantic Ocean
the other contract was awarded to Boeing
who cst-100
our liner capsule is scheduled for its
uncrewed test launch in April 2019 star
liner is designed to be reused at least
ten times within the span of six months
SpaceX and Boeing are continuing tests
but both have committed to manned space
missions for later this year nASA has
already assigned the crew that will be
heading up on these historic flights and
although crew dragon and star liner are
built to carry seven passengers for
these first operational missions they'll
carry only four crew members along with
roughly 100 kilograms of cargo by having
different launch capabilities it
provides more launch options when
needing to replan an aborted launch like
what happened to option and and Hague
back in October this is going to make
the the program much more robust by
having multiple means to launch from
whether it's the US whether it's Boeing
or whether it's space X or or whether
it's on a Soyuz we've got all these ways
to deliver crews so that if we do have a
problem we're more resilient and we
don't have to bring down the size of the
crew of the station and put a you know a
damper on the the research and we can
continue to move forward at the pace
that we want to because at the end of
the day it's also about the really cool
science happening on board the ISS right
now there are roughly 250 scientific
experiments stationed aboard send up on
previous missions from different space
agency partners looking to study various
aspects of life in space these
experiments include how to grow food and
microgravity or monitoring lightning
from space that happens every second or
how astronauts experience bone density
loss during expeditions before heading
up the astronauts get training so
they're able to handle the experiments
and they can even volunteer for them
like the airway monitoring program sent
up by European Space Agency to help
study astronauts loan function on the
ISS the study looks at the nitric oxide
the astronauts breathe out which helps
in understanding the conditions of our
lungs in space monitoring nitric oxide
levels helps to detect inflammatory
diseases in the lungs like asthma
previous crews of astronauts have
volunteered for the experiment like
German ESA astronaut Alexander Gerst and
we also found that spaceflight triggers
a little bit the reaction of the lungs
that are very close to what people have
when they have asthma so we can still
breathe freely in space
it's not really stopping us from working
and living there but we can still use
that little change to measure that right
and we can understand it better because
we are in a much more controlled
environment than it's possible down here
on earth for expedition 59 60
Nick Hague volunteered to be the human
test subject for the experiment so the
benefit is when we get to the surface of
the Moon and there's dust and we know we
had problems with lunar dust back in the
Apollo program we're going to be able to
monitor the health of the astronauts
even better while they're working up
there and and diagnose problems and
protect us while we're exploring the
moon space is not easy it's a it's a
risky business it's always going to be a
risky business but why do we do it
we've been up there for two decades on
the space station in this amazing
international collaboration performing
science collecting data so the
scientists on the ground can learn more
about our planet
they can learn more about humans in our
bodies and and how they behave they can
learn more about the universe that
surrounds us and and all of that is
advancing humanity and so we accept
those risks so that we can continue to
move forward and continue to expand the
boundaries of what we know that's it's a
vital mission and we're doing it every
day and I want people to when they see a
launch like that I want them to connect
that launch with the importance of the
mission and that's just it there are so
many launches happening every year so
many historic moments that aren't to be
missed which is why we're committed to
bringing you more launch coverage than
ever before that means we'll be there to
talk about the next crew Dragon launch
Boeing Starliner
and the latest International moon
missions if there's anything you'd like
us to cover on future missions let us
know down in the comments and as always
thanks for watching seeker and I'll see
you next time